[Music]
sierra starts us off this hour in tacoma
washington hi sierra how are you
better than i deserve how about yourself
just the same how can we help
well i've got a question so
my boyfriend is having a lot of money
troubles and this family is going for
bankruptcy right now
and i'm wondering how i can help
um
does he live at home
yes okay he's 17
17 years old
and uh obviously you guys are just
dating and so i don't want you to help
them financially are you saying more
emotionally how do you help right now
i don't know i just i want to do
something
well they're already through they're
going through the bankruptcy process as
we speak
yeah
how old are you sierra
16
okay
all right
um
yeah the only way you can actually help
in this situation with both of you being
minors and not being married
is just uh love and support emotional
support uh there's it's not your
responsibility or your place and it
would be inappropriate for you to put
money into this scenario
so
you would just
care about him care about his mom and
dad they're scared
he's scared there's a lot of uncertainty
around this even if they're acting like
they're not scared i've been through
bankruptcy it's scary
and um
so you can just support him uh let me
kind of give you a metaphor to think
about all right
how would you help him
if his mom
was going through chemo with cancer
i i just
i'd be there for him exactly
you really can't help his mom
the doctors have to do that
whether she makes it or not is not up to
you
it's up to god and the doctors in my
metaphor that i just made up here my
storyline that i just made up
uh obviously that's not happening at
least i hope it's not um
be a horrible choice of metaphors if it
was but the uh um but but you know the
yeah so i think it's something similar
the difference with the money thing is
it feels like there's something we're
supposed to do to like buy food or
something like that and that's not
necessary in bankruptcy
uh if the are his mom and dad working do
they have jobs
yes okay then they have money for food
even in bankruptcy
yeah okay and they have money for lights
and water
and depending on the type of bankruptcy
and what's going on with the house
there's a strong possibility they'll be
staying in the house
yeah
so we got food shelter clothing
transportation utilities
so the basic necessities of life are
there but it's just um they've they've
obviously made some mistakes
with their money and and now they're
having it they've got you know they've
got a lot of pain because of it
and so if you can just do that if
treated like his mom's got cancer what
would you do you just be there for him
emotionally because he can't fix his
parents situation and neither can you
yeah and he's actually having a hard
time too because um his vehicle is not
working and he's trying to get it fixed
so he can come to work
okay
and uh what does he what does he do when
he's at work
he actually works for my dad um he does
uh we do farm work
okay good
okay
uh what's wrong with this car
um
let's see something in the transmission
broke but it's right in the middle of
the transit transmission so
you have to take it all apart to try to
fix what it is
any of the guys on the farm able to help
with that
um well it's just me and my dad
my sister and my mom we don't really
know how to do do cars a whole lot okay
is his income intact still
your boyfriend
what does he make when he works at the
farm
uh
let's see works two days a week so he
gets about a thousand dollars a month
okay
is he in school right now
yes okay
well we're both homeschooled so
okay all right that's good news all
right well i think he's probably gonna
scrape together a little bit of money
and if your dad as his employer wants to
help him out a little bit with getting
his transmission fixed and let him work
that off that wouldn't be a bad thing i
would do that possibly for one of my
employees here
or i might even give them a gift to help
them get through a rough patch with the
by buying them a used transmission or
something like that i've done that kind
of thing as an employer i don't know if
your dad's in a position to do that
you're not you're 16 you don't give him
money period
okay
if that's my opinion and you asked okay
and i i think you've got a big heart and
i think you are mature beyond your years
you carried yourself well on a radio
show here calling in uh with millions of
people listening at 16 years old you're
an impressive young woman yeah and on
top of that sierra it sounds like he
needs encouragement right now because he
feels like his parents mistakes are his
mistakes and that their lives are going
to become his life and so the best thing
you can do is remind him that it doesn't
have to be that way and as you guys
progress in your relationship if this is
a long-term thing or you guys end up
getting married you can change that
cycle you can change that family tree it
is possible and the fact that you're
calling in gives me a lot of hope that
you you have a heart to want to change
this so you're doing great uh be there
for him but know that you can't change
their situation yeah and if you guys if
your dad again wants to step in and help
him with getting the car fixed or
getting a beater car or got an old
pickup on the farm that you can get
started and let him drive it until he
can get his car fixed or some way like
that to him give him a little direct
help on the car situation only
that's fine
but that's your dad's call
not and it's not a resp and it's not
requirement it would be an act of
generosity on your dad an optional act
on your dad's part but your george is
exactly right i think you remind him
that um
you know everyone has every one of us
that have parented
or that have parents and most of us have
parents
have the idea that we can make better
decisions than they did in the next time
the next generation and that thank
goodness is true thank goodness you have
the option of making better decisions
than your parents did and that's a
universal human thing that we all have
that ability so i think you're going to
be great i appreciate your heart and
appreciate you checking in